-Is ski etiquette
any different over there?
-Yes.
-Very much so.
-They crowd -- They crowd hard
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah, whereas --
-You think of it
as a very polite place.
-I know, but --
-And it is, in many respects
-Still polite.
-Yeah.
-It's very polite,
but they just have
a very aggressive way
of getting on the lift.
There's no -- You know,
in the states it's sort of like,
"We'll take three, a single now.
You know, you four go up."
There, it's just an opening, and
then it's just a massive crowd
And people get so --
Like, their ski's
in between your skis,
and you're so tight.
-Yeah.
-And a lot of, like, this.
-You're just sort of, like..
[ Laughter ]
-With a neutral expression
-"Can I --
Can I give you some room, sir?
Can I give you a little?"
-And then if you were to
look back like, "Excuse me,"
they're just like...
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You are not there.
Yeah.
I would wait five hours
to get on a lift
just 'cause
I would not be aggressive.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I would watch upwards
of 20 people start back ther
and be up and over the mountai
and back down
by the time I got even close
-In the Austrians' defense
it is their national sport
-Yeah.
-They are amazing skiers,
as a population of people.
-Whoo!
-Yes.
-We keep establishing
there's one Austrian.
-Just one Austrian.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, the one Austrian.
-Yeah.
-Really, really psyched for --
-'Cause she wants to
re-establish herself every time.
-Yes, of course.
-You went to a spa?
-Oh, God.
I did go to a spa.
-Yeah.
-Yes, and --
-I feel like this is a thing
people would say,
if you go to Austria,
you have to go to the spas
-Of course, absolutely.
They've got a whole sauna
life there and steam life.
Very sauna.
Anyway, it was our
first weekend there,
and I thought,
"Yeah, I'm gonna go and relax.
I had a down day.
So I go down,
I walk into the sauna,
I've got a towel, I take the
towel off, I sit on the thing.
And the next thing I know,
the door opens, and two --
Oh, I don't know --
men in their 50s, 60s,
quite overweight
and talking a mile a minut
in Austri-- in German.
They come in completely naked,
and I am so shocked.
I just --
-So you had no expectation
of the co-ed steam room?
-I didn't really
understand that.
And I just put my head down,
prayed to Jesus Christ
I didn't know them particularl
well, and skedaddled.
[ Laughter ]
It was bad.
-See, I had the same experience,
except I went in,
and I was the first one in
-Yeah.
-And then this man came in
and laid down almost like as i
his head was on my lap.
-Oh, dear.
-And I was like --
-I was tired.
-And I just sort of sat ther
and was like, "Oh, I don't kno
what's happening."
And then,
after about 10 minutes,
he finally gets up, and he goes,
"Oh, hey, Nat."
And it was our D.P.
It was our cinematographer
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "Oh, I thought
we had a great day out there
I got a lot of great shots."
And I was like, "We did get
lot of great shots, Danny.
And then he wanted to talk about
the day's work ahead,
and I couldn't look anywhere
It was incredibly awkward.
-Yeah.
-One of your co-stars,
Zach Woods, was here.
-Yes.
-He was talking about
one of the things
about this film was
you obviously spent
a couple months at a resort,
had to eat a lot of meals
at the resort restaurant.
Do you feel as though
they were sad to see you g
when the film was over?
-Not so much.
-I don't know.
Not so much.
[ Laughter ]
-Right?
-Yeah.
-I mean, they didn't --
We didn't get a particularly
warm goodbye or anything.
-Yeah.
Did you get a warm welcome
Were they excited
about American movie
or was that not even that --
-You know, not that much.
-Not certainly when we wer
using ski lifts and gondolas
-Yeah.
-Most people who go on vacatio
and pay a lot of money
to go on vacation
do not want to watch
a holiday movie --
a Hollywood movie shut down th
ski lift to get you up there
And we would have to do sort of,
like, NASCAR, sort of like
change the cameras away fast
and so there would be
a collection of skiers
just collecting and collecting
and then they'd start
shouting stuff in German,
which most likely was not, like,
"We love movies!"
[ Laughter ]
-"Take your time!"
-"Can't wait to see it!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-"Is this gonna be
a wide release?!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"What's the plot?"
-And did you --
Did you eat a lot of --
Zach was saying there was
some very weird service.
Do you feel like --
That the waiters were --
I don't know --
maybe a little brusque.
-Very.
-Yeah.
-I remember the women
at the supermarket.
I don't know if anyone
had that -- that --
-Oh, yes.
-I remember that
being a challenge because I --
you know, the first --
I was trying to --
-I didn't go to the market
-You didn't go to the market
-No, no.
But I remember you saying --
-You went to Switzerland,
though.
-Yeah.
-Don't sell yourself short
-We were actually upset
that he came back.
[ Laughter ]
We were like, "We did it!"
But he found his way back.
So, you do what you can.
But, no, I remember, you would
go to the supermarket,
and it's very fast-paced.
And so what they do is,
you put your stuff up, and you
have to bag your own stuff
and so the women would quickly
throw them down to the other
and if you weren't ready,
they'd put a big wood bloc
between you and the next people.
So, by the end, I was like
"I'm gonna do this.
I'm gonna beat you.
I'm gonna beat you."
So I was bagging it
so appropriately, and then I -
I got some apples.
This is a 20-minute story.
[ Laughter ]
I got some apples,
and then she starts
getting very upset with me
and I wasn't understanding
but apparently,
I saw there was, like,
an apple box crate
that had been ripped,
and I had pulled some
out of that,
and you're not
supposed to rip it.
You're supposed to
buy all the apples.
-Got it.
-So I knew what she was saying
I go, "It's okay, it's okay.
I don't need it.
I don't need it."
No one's sort of helping
translate anything
that's happening.
I say, "Just keep it,
keep it, keep it."
Finally, she just says,
"Take it."
I think that's
what she's saying to me.
[ Laughter ]
-"We love movies!"
-"Take your time!"
-"Take your time!
You're doing great.
I'm enjoying you."
And so, I put them in my thing
And then this guy,
one guy looks up,
and his accent says, "Don'
worry. They hate everybody."
[ Laughter ]
-This has been so wonderfu
having all four of you here.
Thank you, so much, you guys
[ Cheers and applause ]
Julia Louis-Dreyfus,
Will Ferrell,
Nat Faxon, Jim Rash.